I know what you're thinking miss walters when
i'm not erasing everyone's memories not again
yeah it's also a very very messy believe me. Welcome
back everyone it's charlie this will be my full
marvel she-hulk episode 3 video there were a whole
bunch of easter eggs and references bunch of cameo
scenes as well which they also called out with
fourth wall breaks so we'll break it all down if
you're new to the channel i'll be doing videos for
all the episodes be sure to subscribe to get them
we're also having marvel disney plus day pretty
soon they're going to be releasing a whole bunch
of trailers i'll be doing videos for all that
stuff as well too careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet we'll start at the
beginning and work our way through shot by shot
talking about easter eggs and wtf moments as we
go along the episode was titled the people versus
emil blonsky which is all about him getting out
of prison which they do achieve during the episode
but also you have the b storyline which they
also called out in a fourth wall break like
ah connecting the a and the b story nice job
there with a version of her former co-worker at
the district attorney's office dennis trying to
fight a light elf to get his money back who had
been pretending to be megan thee stallion setting
up her big cameo during the episode probably like
the second biggest cameo in the episode if you
consider wong because it really was a big wong
episode but it's just the beginning of wong during
the series like he shows up to help abomination
get out of prison but also explains what was
going on during the events of shangshi like
why they were having that fight in the ring and
turns out it was not about sandwich money but the
actual opening scene of the episode is abomination
explaining what happened during that shangxi scene
he blames it all on wong forcing him to leave his
cell saying that he also returned of his own free
will that's also part of a long con that i think
he's pulling here like why he would choose to come
back to the cell instead of choosing to take
the asylum that wong offered him in kamar taj
because if he taken wong up on his offer for
asylum he never would have been able to leave
kamar taj that he would have been arrested on
site the minute he stepped out of kamar taj
they showed the a113 easter egg again yes it is
a big pixar reference like the founders of pixar
all had classic cal arts in a special room a113 so
the a113 easter egg is featured in a lot of pixar
movies pixar is disney now so that's probably how
it found its way in here the other funny thing
here too is the easter egg about wong's employment
history with his linkedin page like this is meant
to be wong having an actual linkedin page in the
mcu which he updated recently after the events of
avengers endgame i know a lot of the references
that wong makes during the episode make the
timeline a little confusing i'll explain that in a
second too when we get to that part of the episode
because they use jokes about spider-man no way
home even though this has been to take place
before that so don't worry i will explain the
timeline but apparently before wong became a
sorcerer in kamar taj he was just a regular worker
at target for a little while and i love the idea
that the target that he actually worked at before
he joined the order of sorcerers was actually at
comartage i think the joke there is that they have
a lot of regular businesses like you would find
in any regular city the only thing that's kind of
weird with the logic here is because wang makes it
seem like he doesn't really care about american
laws yet he still wants an actual linkedin page
like why does he need a linkedin page what does he
care about that he does make a couple jokes later
in the episode reciting his full title like it's
a really long title since he's become sorcerer's
supreme so i think it's more of an ego thing on
his part like he just wants to hear people say
that he is a source of supreme a little bit
she breaks the fourth wall to tell us again
that it's not a show just about the cameos every
week because there are special cameos every week
like that is the joke like they do have special
cameos every single week joking that we're just
waiting for wong's cameo like i know you're here
just waiting for that long cameo but remember who
show is this as cool as all the wong stuff is i
know we're really just waiting to see matt murdock
daredevil show up after the she-hulk title they
have a big montage of a bunch of news stations
doing celebrity gossip about she-hulk herself and
what she's doing trying to get an abomination out
of prison there's a little chiron at the bottom of
the first one joking about titania thinking that
our lawyer is going to make all of our problems go
away supposedly titania won't be a big character
again until episode five so it's still going
to be a couple episodes before she comes back
you notice in the background here the picture that
they actually use for abomination is a combo of
his newer appearance during the shangshi movie in
the photo is actually a human photo they took from
the events of the incredible hulk movie another
reference to that incredible hulk movie that's
why tim roth looks so much younger in the photo
they use a youtube player again to show you a
bunch of she-hulk related celebrity gossip videos
that people have uploaded the last time they used
youtube in the mcu was during the miss marvel
series because of her sloth baby productions
that she uploads all of her videos to they have
a big montage of a bunch of people hating on her
some of these names are easter eggs some of them
not some of them just meant to be like funny jokes
dom the bouncy hunter here for example is dog the
bounty hunter most of these names like i said i
think are just meant to be jokes they're not like
direct references to any real-life people but if
you think you spot some other easter eggs and some
of the names just write it below in the comments
a lot of the jokes are similar to jokes that
people have been telling about her in real
life like people calling her a version of fiona
from shrek you have a couple people that want to
smash her playing smash or pass but because she's
she-hulk their catchphrase is literally smash like
she-hulk smash most of the news broadcasters are
not from the comics they just created all this
stuff for the show a couple of them are comic
book characters though like gideon wilson here
that they bring on the original attorney who put
abomination behind bars in the mcu is based on a
comic book character that debuted during world
war hulk but this version of the character is a
little bit different from the comic book version
they're really just kind of using the name from
that world war hulk storyline but there's been
all this talk about then doing a world war hulk
movie we have all those easter eggs and previous
episodes so this is just like the latest world war
hulk easter egg and also just because hulk left
the planet to go back to sakaar seemingly he will
be back in future episodes like we did see a scene
with him with titania so at some point during the
series he will come back and hopefully he'll tell
us what he did while he was off planet when her
boss calls her into his office she hesitates for
a second getting ready to answer the phone as she
look like hello she-hulk here but she corrects
herself and says hello it's jennifer walters
the dennis character is based on a comic book
character dennis bukowski in the comics he was
just a rival lawyer to she-hulk he didn't have
any special powers he was just a dirtbag who
eventually got his comeuppance and they kind of do
the same thing with the character in this episode
like i said last week too josh segarra who
most of you probably remember is prometheus on
arrow is playing pug he's just another comic book
character who worked with she-hulk and has a huge
crush on her he's just meant to be like a nice
character in the comics who tries to help her out
the mallory character here is also another comic
book character that she hulk works with at her law
firm in the comics she also doesn't have any
special powers either she's just like another
lawyer working at that same firm they explained
dennis was dating a light elf who's staying at
new asgard because her father is a diplomat from
alphine that's where the light elves come from
they actually reference that during thor love and
thunder that's the planet that thor goes to when
he finds the body of falagar the behemoth gore's
latest victim and sif and this is the whole plot
line with her pretending to be megan thee stallion
setting up her cameo scene later in the episode
gotta say did not expect to see that she-hulk
twerking would become cannon to the mcu that was
a bit of a surprise use the version of that song
in my video and see how quickly it gets claimed
on youtube then they start the running jokes with
wong's storyline and him not really understanding
or caring about like the really common american
laws like i have bigger problems to worry about
who cares about all this little stuff
that you're talking about he explains
that he broke the abomination out of prison
not because of sandwich money but because
he was practicing the art of kumite in his bid to
become source of supreme trying to test his medal
kumite is actually a real life thing like it's a
freestyle martial arts type of fight but i think
the way that he references kumite in the episode
it's meant to be more of a jean-claude van damme
blood sport reference because that's the name of
the tournament that he fights in during that movie
and it is a classic if you haven't seen bloodsport
i would recommend it when he starts talking about
the book of ashanti higher order cosmic things at
play and she's talking about the book of american
laws that's meant to be a reference to all the
bigger cosmic things that are happening through
the events of spider-man no way home doctor
strange multiverse of madness and eventually
thor love and thunder when he starts talking about
not erasing people's memories not doing that again
that obviously is meant to be a joke about
spiderman no way home because that's literally
what doctor strange did during that movie but
you have to remember per what the showrunner
and the marvel people have said this is meant
to take place relatively soon after the end
of the shangxi movie so it's before the events
of spider-man no way home in doctor strange 2.
so when wang is making this joke doctor strange
hasn't actually made that first spell yet
so it's kind of a meta easter egg so really
it's more of a joke about what will happen
instead of what's already happened and when he
says i'm not doing that spell again he's talking
about the party the doctor strange reference
that happened to kamar taj remember the spell
you used to erase everyone's memory after that
crazy party oh no we're not doing that again
when he references the mirror dimension obviously
another reference to spider-man no way home
because they fought in the mirror dimension and
also to doctor strange multiverse of madness
because later in the timeline they will eventually
try to trap scarlet witch there unsuccessfully
when he references the shadow dimension i think
that's meant to be more of a reference to the dark
dimension because there is no shadow dimension
inside marvel comics like there's a shadow realm
which is kind of a connection to thor love and
thunder and there is a dark dimension that's the
dimension that dormammu rules over that clia also
comes from so i think it's meant to be more of a
reference to that like oh we could always send the
abomination to the dark dimension they said at the
running gag with the light elf shape-shifting into
other characters trying to get out of all of her
troubles you also notice when dennis calls pug
tipping him off that it is the shapeshifter he's
complaining about his cyber truck cyber trucks
have actually not been released like in real life
tesla has not started selling cyber trucks but i
think the logic works because you have to remember
that avengers end game ended in 2023 in real
life as i'm posting this video today it's 2022
with the idea that cyber trucks will be released
in the next year or two kevin feige always says
that they try to avoid real world connections
like that because sometimes the timeline won't
work out because of some big twist or the way
that they edit a movie and it just winds up
causing more problems than it solves so that's why
you don't see a ton of dates inside marvel movies
everybody having flashbacks to that spider-man
homecoming scene of the eight years later
they make a joke about her outside the prison
about being rejected by the avengers she hasn't
actually technically met the other avengers if
hulk really wanted to make her officially part
of the team he'd have to get a consensus from
the ones that are still alive and there aren't
that many core avengers who are still around who
could actually vote on that so she'd have to have
another scene like she had at the end of his movie
where wong's like welcome to the team and they
welcome to the avengers but that's because there
are a couple avengers there in the room we meet
abomination seven mystery soul mates that he said
he met while in prison and they're just women who
fell in love with him and bought him the land that
we see in later episodes in the trailers they play
like a little bit more of a cult situation like
they're my soul mates obviously he doesn't plan
to actually get married to all of them most of
this is part of his long con to get out of prison
when they're stalling for time so that wong
can show up any waffles of the parole board
when he's talking about changing cosmically
interdimensionally physically metaphysically
spiritually etc all that's true technically
because of what's happened just in a cosmic sense
to the mcu since the events of avengers infinity
war with all the snaps and then she-hulk is also
correct in saying that he is not the same emil
blonsky as he was before when he committed all
these crimes because literally they have changed
the appearance of the abomination character
hulk also made a similar type of edward norton
joke like literally i am not the same person
in the trailers we've actually seen the meditation
retreat that they mentioned in the episode
so it looks like there's going to be like a
multi-episode arc for this abomination stuff
when they start talking more about the
light elf we learned her name is runa
that is a character from the comics but runa in
the comics was one of the original valkyrie order
part of the thor comics they do make a lot of thor
references with new asgard but this mcu version of
the character is just using the name she makes
the odin joke from thor ragnarok asgard is not
a place it's a people apparently thor's speech
is now common knowledge because the judge didn't
even need to hear her say the word thor to know
that thor was the one that spoke those out loud
and when wong starts talking about offering
abomination asylum in kamar taj like i said it's
all part of his bid to get out of prison so that
it can be legit and he can be free to go wherever
he wants to go if he took asylum and kamar taj
he never would have been able to leave camartage
he pulls the same trick that she hulk pulled in
episode 1 hooking out and going back to normal
to prove that he's in control while in abomination
form but part of the terms of his parole are that
it can never turn into abomination for the rest of
his life and also for the rest of his life he has
to wear the same type of inhibitor that bruce
banner hulk was wearing in the first episode
before their accident in those other trailer
scenes we actually see him in abomination form
inside that property that the seven women buy
for him so either he violates the terms of his
parole or something else happens and that just
does not stick love the way that wong bails on
the episode too when they start to question him
about admitting to committing a crime like wait
a minute sir you technically just admitted that
you committed a crime he's like up i gotta go
peace out he will be back in future episodes as
part of another trial like he'll be trying to sue
another person pretending to be a magician they
make another genie reference which is sort of a
call back to ms marvel because they talked about
gin during that series but the gin that they talk
about are different creatures from traditional
genies she breaks the fourth wall again to just
comment on them connecting both the subplots on
the episode like ah nice job there connecting both
plots and they tied together both of the story
lines when we see the girls agreed to testify
during dennis's trial that he is in fact a total
idiot they also use the rest of the trial to pay
off the megan thee stallion name drops when she
appears at the courtroom for the sentencing and
now she's candid to the mcu becoming she-hulk's
next client like she just becomes her lawyer but
obviously the big deal here is abomination getting
out of prison and starting the meditation retreat
i'll talk more about that in next week's episode
too because a lot of the people that come to his
meditation retreats are b and c-list villains from
like the daredevil comics and the punisher comics
just talking about the netflix marvel characters
coming back to the mcu of course there'd be a lot
of daredevil and punisher characters everybody
just waiting for the punisher to come back into
the mcu too when she jokes about liking it or not
she's going to forever be the she-hulk that's also
a true statement because even though there might
be some future twists where she's able to negate
her powers briefly that won't stick obviously and
she'll just continue being she-hulk for the rest
of her time in the mcu but when dennis gives
her the idea to negate power she's probably
going to use that to eventually try and get rid
of her powers but i think that's not going to
stick like i said because like at the end of
the episode the wrecking crew comes to fight
her i'll explain them in a second too but she
hooks out uses her powers and then kind of looks
at herself in she-hulk form and she starts to
like a little bit like oh okay this isn't so bad
when she winds up fighting the wrecking crew
though that is a marvel villain team it like
the thunderball character that they mention here
is a character that's part of the wrecking crew
it looks like they're all using magically enhanced
items and they claimed that they were there to try
and get a sample of her blood for a mystery boss
quote-unquote it could be val could be part of
all the thunderbolt stuff they're setting up them
wanting to gain the powers of the hulk they set
that up in episode one too where the hulk is like
you need to burn all these samples of your blood
we don't need more hulks running around out there
and that's what this mystery boss wants her blood
samples to try and use her powers to recreate
more hulks so either it could be val or it could
just be a character that's specific to the whole
comics like the leader you guys can let me know
in the comments like who is that mystery person
that wants to get her powers when she's fighting
them she also makes a joke about them robbing an
asgardian construction worker that's meant to be
an eric masterson joke which is also a bit of
a thor love and thunder joke because they based
his ravager costume on eric masterson's costume
then during the end credits they have a brand
new song and the new scenes that they added to
this comic book art are the abomination leaving
prison with the women coming after him there's
a new scene of nicki in their office there's a
scene depicting dennis at what he thinks is
a date with megan thief stein i think it's
meant to be a depiction of his earlier dates with
the light elf shape-shifting into the character
but in the actual post-credits scene they pay
off the megan thee stallion joke with her signing
she-hulk to become her new lawyer with them
twerking to one of her songs never thought that i
would see that in the mcu she-hulk twerking in it
being like a cannon thing usually that's something
you see in like some crazy fan video they also
make a joke about she-hulk being a fan girl of
hers saying i will kill anybody for you but if you
spotted any other easter eggs in the episode that
i didn't talk about in the video just write them
below in the comments like i said episode 4 will
probably be more of the abomination plot of him in
that retreat with the other punisher and daredevil
villains i'm not sure which episode wong is coming
back for and i'm not sure which episodes daredevil
will be in i believe he'll be in a couple
episodes my she-hulk episode 4 trailer video
will post next i've got a bunch of other videos
that i'm working on too also lord of the rings
episode 1 and episode 2 are dropping on thursday
night so my video for those will post on friday
there's going to be a bunch of episodes from
a bunch of different huge series so everyone's
going to be eating pretty good for like the next
10 weeks or so everyone click here for my house
of the dragon episode 3 trailer video and click
here for my full house the dragon episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!